- We've got one more super
sweet story for the hour.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
It takes utter commitment to
prepare and run a marathon.
I wouldn't know, but I've heard it does.
26 miles is a lot of miles to not drive.
So after all that training,
it takes a truly big heart
to stop in the middle of the race
to rescue a kitten, which is so cute.
That's just what one Chicago woman did
at the 20th mile marker, stopping her
from breaking her personal best time.
And also, that's a lot of miles.
Your body's gotta feel heavy
at that point to add a kitten.
I don't care how much it
weighs, it seems like a lot.
And before the race was over,
she found that kitten a perfect new home.
She did a lot, okay, during that race.
We have that runner on the line right now,
along with the mama of the rescued cat.
Let's say hello to Sarah and Andrea
watching on NBC Chicago.
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Kelly.
- What's up y'all?
- So Sarah, tell us
about finding the kitten.
- Okay, I was at mile 20,
I'm focused on my race
and I remember running into this tunnel.
I'm like, "Okay, I have six miles to go.
I can get there," and I turn to the left.
I see this little fluffy cat
in a pile of leaves looking terrified.
I remember at that moment, it
was a split second decision,
and I scooped this little baby up.
Walking along the course,
I'm asking spectators,
can you take this cat?
I remember seeing Andrea in the crowd.
She stepped forward and
she was so compassionate.
She had said, "I'm a cat mom myself.
I will re-home this cat.
I'll love this cat with all my heart."
And at that point, I handed him off to her
and I haven't seen him since.
- Ah, well Andre, that couldn't
have been your checklist
of things to do that day,
so how did that happen?
- So, not at all.
I've been going out there
cheering on the runners
for 20 years with my family.
So it was like a normal year,
and we were all out there
and this woman's in her running outfit.
And she has this cute little
kitty and it's so adorable.
And she's asking people in the crowd,
"Can you give it a home?"
And then when we met, I was
like, in a split second,
I thought to myself, "Can
I?" and I said, "Yes I can."
We brought him home and
we're very happy with him.
His name's Casper and
he's doing very good.
My family loves him, the kids love him.
And we're just so happy to
have him as part of our family.
- Oh my gosh, I wish I weren't allergic.
They're so cute.
(audience laughs)
- Oh yeah, definitely cute.
- Thank you so much, Sarah, for having
such a kind heart, also an athletic one.
And Andrea, thank you
for taking the kitty in.
Casper is super cute.
Look at the little paw, oh my god.
I'm liking your post right
now, but that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot, pen makers
of Precise the go-to pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate animal
lovers just like y'all.
So they're giving you $1,000,
$500 each just for being rad.
(audience applauds)
Thank you guys so much.
Thanks to all our guests this hour,
Kevin James, Renata Notni,
Charles Esten, and Elana.
And y'all have a great day
and if it's not, change it.